[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces images encore proches appartiennent
à l'année passée 1963 aur avant tout
était marqué par l'écho des trois coups
de feu tirés d'une fenêtre de
Dallas instinctivement chacun s'est
senti concerné par l'assassinat du
président Kennedy mêlé à la douleur
d'une famille frappée au
[Musique]
cœur au cimetière d'Arlington la
présence des plus haut représentant de
50 Nations a traduit cette émotion
générale et souligné l'importance de la
charge qui incombait désormais au
nouveau président Lyndon
Johnson John Kennedy avait engagé le
monde sur le chemin de la détente
Est-Ouest la population de berlin- ouest
avait pu l'acclamer en même temps que
celle de Berlin Est acclamait monsieur
krutchov sans que le monde trembla 1962
avait été l'année de la crise cubaine
1963 fut celle du téléphone rouge et de
la liaison directe entre la Maison
Blanche et le
kemelin la vie internationale ne fut pas
toutefois exinte de remou il y eu le
coup d'État qui coûta la vie au général
Kassem en Irak et un mois après celui de
[Applaudissements]
Damas mais dans l'écho de cette
effervescence du Moyen-Orient on vit
l'Afrique prendre pour la première fois
à Addis Abeba conscience de son unité et
les coups de feu échangés au confin
saharien entre l'Algérie et le Maroc
n'urent pas les conséquences
désastreuses qu'on avait pu craindre à
bamaco les frères devenus ennemis pour
ind différent de frontière se
[Musique]
retrouvèrent c'est peut-être saon qui
connut les remous les plus violents le
président di et sa famille furent les
victimes d'une journée sanglante dans un
climat de nouvelle liberté les belles
saigonaises retrouvèrent les joies twist
à en perdre le
souffle à dire vrai on parla beaucoup en
1963 de la pluie et du beau temps ou
plus exactement du mauvais temps
Montmartre devenu station de sport
d'hiver les canaux gelés où des
centaines de péniches restèent bloqué
avec leur chargement de charbon
alimentèrent bien des conversations
n'allaon pas jusqu'à signaler en
île-defance le retour des loups qui se
révél être en définitif de braves chien
loup on vit la mer du Nord formé en
banquise et ne s'amusaton pas à
organiser en Hollande des rally
automobiles sur le zideré
[Musique]
gelé le monde entier grelotta le froid
bâti partout des records du Japon où
l'on n'arrivait pas à se débarrasser des
tonnes de neiges à moncelé en dépit de
train spécialement frêés à cet usage aux
chutes du Niagara soudain presque
immobilisé dans un rêve de glace du plus
bel
effet à quelque chose malheur est la
mode en profita pour réinventer les
bottes et des bataillons d'élégantes et
gouttières à l'air porter à Londres le
nouveau caprice de
Paris on ne voulut pas être en restre
manche et les troupeaux de bouton y
gagnèrent une élégance
nouvelle il reste que 1963 connu son
cortège d'image tragique le tremblement
de terre qui détruisit scopier capitale
de la Macédoine fit 2000
morts
Cuba après la Martinique après Haïti se
débattit contre l'un des plus violents
cyclones qui se soit déchaîné sur les
Caraïbes 1000 morts 100000 sans
[Musique]
abris c'est encore la catastrophe du
barrage de von qui Raya de la carte
langaron et h autres villages d'Italie
et fit 4000
[Musique]
victimes c'est enfin l'explosion du
Colisée d'Indianapolis qui termina le
spectacle
en tragédie épouvantable 62
morts des figures célèbres ont disparu
de la scène la chanteuse edit Piaf et le
même jour le poète Jean
cocto le père du cubisme le peintre
George brac l'un des pères de l'Europe
Robert
Schuman le vent de l'histoire devait
emporter aussi un grand pape l'église
perdit après 5 ans de règne Jean 2 qui
lui avait donné une impulsion nouvelle
en réunissant le concile écuménique en
reprenant en main les clés de
Saint-Pierre le cardinal Montini devenu
le pape Paul VI allait poursuivre cette
œuvre et même en décidant le voyage de
Jérusalem lui donner encore plus de
relief en France toujours acclamé par
les foules au cours de ses voyages le
général de Gaul fit porter l'essentiel
de son effort sur les problèmes
européens et les derniers jours de
l'année lui donnè raison en voyant
aboutir à Bruxelles l'accord agricole
qui crée l'Europe verte au terme d'un
ultime marathon qui fit
sensation le début de cette même année
avait vu la conclusion du traité
franco-allemand de coopération que
signèrent le général de Gaulle et le
chancelier ad noer dont ce fut le
dernier acte avant de céder sa place au
chancelier
era la vie anglaise quant à elle qu'on
disait s'y réservé fut bouleversé par
une certaine Miss killer ce qui entraîna
le suicide d'un ostéopathe célèbre le
docteur Ward et par la suite la
démission du Premier ministre monsieur
mcman auquel Lord humum succéda au
gouvernement et à la tête du Parti
[Musique]
conservateur en même temps l'attaque à
la mode du Far West d'un train postal en
pleine Angleterre et en plein 20e siècle
faisait également quelques
bruit mais passons les sujets de Sa
Majesté ne manquèrent pas pour autant de
sujets de satisfaction
la visite à Londres du Roi Baudouin et
de la reine Fabiola que la reine
ellisabeth et le duc d'Édimbourg
conduisirent en carrosse à travers
Londres renoua entre les deux couronnes
les liens d'une vieille
[Musique]
amitié Bruxelles connut quelques
agitation suscité par la querelle
linguistique le rendez-vous des Belges
succéda au Rassemblement wallon et à la
marche des
Flamands plus grave fut l'explosion
raciale qui agita les États-Unis et plus
spécialement l'Alabama
[Musique]
la marche des Noirs conduisit à
Washington 200000 manifestants réclamant
l'égalité de fête entre blanc et
noir les Américains avaient eu en tout
cas une satisfaction pour la première
fois la Joconde avait traversé l'océan
pour venir leur
souris les Français naturellement blasés
se tournaient plutôt vers des célébrités
moins RAC à 18 ans François hardard
comme ch 17 devenait tê
d'affiche au jeun la devise générale
était d'être yé pour respecter les goûts
d'une jeunesse débordante qui consommait
une quantité incroyable de guitares
électriques place au jeunes on vit même
triompher dans les arènes espagnoles la
classe
[Musique]
biberon même le domaine des fusées ne
put échapper à la soif de s'affirmer de
centaines de Verner von Brown en
[Musique]
herbe 15
ans deux records de natation auprès
d'elle Michel JAAS faisait figure de
vieux il bâtit néanmoins dans l'année
les records du 1500 m et du 2
[Musique]
miles l'avenir était au jeunes et
l'Amérique se mit à faire
électroniquement le compte de la
jeunesse dès la
naissance un progrès entraînant l'autre
la roue sur laquelle nous avons vécu
quelques siècles commença même sur les
machines agricoes a cédé la place au
coussin d'air elle gagna pourtant un
autre titre de noblesse dans les usines
japonaises au profit de la
productivité le bœuf cède à la place au
pétrole qui abonde comme on sait on
réussit à en tirer un biftech au goût de
fromage aigre et la production du poulet
atteignit aux États-Unis son plus haut
degré de rendement on mangerait donc
encore demain iriton dans la lune la
conquête de l'espace aura un peu marqué
le pas malgré les 22 tours de terre de
Gordon Cooper et malgré l'accession au
titre envier de cosmonaute de la
première femme Valentina terkov
mais les fusées continuent de monter
normalement vers les étoiles et on
n'attendra plus bien longtemps le moment
de voger vers d'autres monde attendons
ce que nous réserve
[Musique]
1964 à la veille des Jeux Olympiques
d'insbrck les grands spécialistes du
saut au tremplin ont pris les devant en
participant au compétitions
internationales du début de la saison et
notamment au saut de Garmish sparten
Kirchen en albagne de l'Ouest le le
tremplin de garmich est l'un des plus
impressionnants du monde sur ce tremplin
en effet ce ne sont plus des skilleurs
il se métamorphose on dirait des
[Musique]
oiseaux les oiseaux qui perdent parfois
leurs ailes en cours de route triste
retour à la réalité pour ceux qui
croyaient déjà avoir vaincu
l'espace mais peu importe pour les
autres les réussite sont
[Musique]
triumphal c'est le cas des fin ais Konen
et alonen qui sont vraiment les maîtres
de la
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
spécialité niiki la capitale de Chypre
vient à nouveau de connaître les
épreuves sanglantes qu'avait semblé
réglé en 1959 la conférence de Londres
cette conférence où l'Angleterre
représenté par Monsieur selwin Lyd
abandonnait la tutelle de l'île et où
Monseigneur macarios devenant le leader
d'un pays indépendant ouvrait une are
nouvelle que la population de Chypre
toute entière grec et turque accueillait
avec ferveur les ans ont passé et
l'enthousiasme est tombé entre les
450000 Grecs et les 100000 Turcs qui
vivent à Chypre les querelles
ancestrales se sont réveillées et le
sang a recommencé de couler pris en
amphilade par les tireurs isolés la rue
Ledra l'artère la plus animée de nikoszi
qui sépare les deux quartiers grec et
turc est devenu la rue rue
sanglante cette terrifiante atmosphère a
créé dans les quartiers proches une
panique bien compréhensible et il a
fallu évacuer hors de la ville des
familles entières chassées de leur foyer
par la crainte des combats de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rue
quant à la minorité turque elle s'est
barricadé dans le quartier où elle vit
rassemblé gardé à chaque coin de rue par
des barricades de fortune occupé par des
volontaires à la détente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
facile jours
dur terreur des réactions imprévisibles
des deux camps le CESS le feu décidaé
d'un common accord sur l'intervention du
représentant de l'Angleterre monsieur
dunc Sandis et la remise au général Jung
du commandement des troupes
anglo-greco-turques stationné dans l'île
ont ramené le calme pour un
[Musique]
temps mais d'autres incidents sanglants
renaissaient en d'autres point le
monastère grec de galactoforousa avait
été attaqué par un commando de cypriote
turc et l'on n retrouvait que des
cadavres la trêve mal respectée avait
des fissures où la violence de part et
d'autre se donnait encore libre
cours et la liste des morts n'est sans
doute hélas pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
définitive pour cette population
déchirée le sang et les larmes sont les
mêmes chez les Grecs que chez les Turcs
il faut que cesse ce drame entre deux
communautés établies et condamné à vivre
ensemble sur la même
[Musique]
terre lorsque sur l'aéroport d'Aman où
l'attendait le roi husin la silhouette
blanche de Paul 6 se dessina à la porte
de l'avion le monde entier put se dire
que commençait une aventure aux
résonances infinie
en effet jamais aucun pape depuis
Saint-Pierre ne s'est rendu sur cette
terre où le Christ naquit vécu et mouru
dans son geste Paul 6 avait enfermé un
sens de portée incalculable la main
tendue aux églises séparées et
l'assurance que le sens écuménique de
l'église était sa première préoccupation
sur la route d'Aman à Jérusalem en pays
jordanien le Saint-Père voulut faire sa
première halte au pont du Jourdain à
l'endroit où selon la tradition Jésus
reçut le baptême des mains de
Jean-Baptiste ainsi se marquait dès la
première heure l'esprit dans lequel le
Saint-Père accomplissait son voyage il
retrouvait les pas du
[Musique]
Christ ce voyage était donc d'abord un
pèlerinage mais l'enthousiasme de la
foule jordanienne en faisait à l'arrivée
à Jérusalem et dans le long cheminement
de la voie douloureuse une que eu un
vrai semblable où le pape disparaissait
presque
complètement
dans la nuit maintenant complète devant
la basilique du Saint Sépulcre le
Saint-Père célébra sa première messe en
Terre sainte avant d'aller se recueillir
dans la crypte où fut enseveli le corps
du Christ et où l'on voit toujours la
pierre du
[Musique]
tombeau le lendemain à Mido Sa Sainteté
Pauls entrait en Israël où répondant au
souhait de bienvenue du président de la
République israélienne monsieur chazar
le pape ajoutait à son discours fait en
français le mot hébreu qui est à la fois
un salut et un souhait Chalom la
paix Nazareth où le Christ vécut son
enfance où il fut ouvrier charpentier
attendait le pape avec
[Musique]
Fiè
dans la ville qui compte aujourd'hui
35000 habitants le pape allait bénir les
murs de l'église inachevée de
l'Annonciation toujours au milieu d'une
foule dont la chaleur rompant parfois
les barrages l'emportait dans ses
[Applaudissements]
Remus le voyage continuait vers la
montagne sainte du Tabor une basilique
marque l'endroit où Jésus apparut à
trois de ses disciples dans la gloire et
la lumière de sa transfiguration divine
par un chemin semé de rose le pape s'en
est allé méditer sur ces lieux sacrés où
commença la grande aventure apostolique
par les mots dits à Pierre vous serez
pêcheurs
[Musique]
d'hommees c'est au retour à Jérusalem
que devait se dérouler l'un des actes
les plus importants de ce voyage
historique Paul VI rencontrait
aténagoras 1er patriarche de
Constantinople et premier pontif des
églises orthodoxes séparé de Rome depuis
10 siècles rencontre pleine d'espoir
dont le sens se dégage peut-être plus
entier au tout premier berceau du
christianisme à Bethléem qui au-dessus
des frontières de barbelé a fait voler
les
[Applaudissements]
colons c'est encore au milieu d'une
foule compacte que le successeur de
Saint-Pierre est allé prier à église de
la Nativité élevée au-dessus de la
grotte où naquis celui qui annonça la
paix pour les hommes de bonne volonté
c'est peut-être sa méditation en ce lieu
sacré qui inspira au pape Paul VI le
pressin appel à la paix qu' adressa à
tous les chefs d'État et à tous les
peuples qu'il cabord plus efficacement
pour obtenir la paix et la vérité dans
la justice dans une liberté et dans un
amour
fraternel pour la 8e fois une fusée
américaine Delta a placé sur orbite un
satellite Tyros un de ces satellites
météorologiques équipés de caméras pour
enregistrer l'image des nuages et la
retransmettre aux stations terrestres
mais c'est la première fois que la
France avec le Centre d'études et
télécommunications de l'anion participe
à cette nouvelle technique de la
prévision du
temps la station de l'anion compte
désormais parmi les 55 stations équipées
pour recevoir les photos prises à 1500
km d'altitude par Tyros 8 qu'une antenne
guettete dans le
ciel dans sa course autour de la Terre
qui lui permet de balayer toute la
surface du globe le satellite passe
plusieurs fois dans la zone de
visibilité de laanon et lors de ses
passages dans cette zone les photos
qu'il prend peuvent être capté par le
Centre Français sur ordre de la terre
l'antenne spéciale reçoit les signaux
émis par Tyros et ces signaux sont alors
transformés en photographie par un
système analogue au traditionnel
[Musique]
bellinographe
ce n'est alors plus qu'un jeu pour les
météorologistes de situer sur une carte
à l'aide d'une grille correspondante à
la photographie les formations nuageuse
qui intéresse toute une
région ici par exemple celle qui va du
golfe de Gascogne au Maroc ainsi pour
a-on procéder de proche en proche et de
station en station et finalement obtenir
la carte complète des nuages qui
entourent le globe
pour une région donnée comme ici la
péninsule ibérique des enregistrements
successifs permettront de connaître
l'évolution des masses nuageuses et du
même coup d'en déduire la prévision du
temps les précédents tios ont déjà
permis de repérer de terribles cyclones
et d'avertir la population 24 heur avant
leur manifestation avec Ti suite la
météo dispose aujourd'hui d'une arme
encore plus
[Musique]
perfectionnée
la mode parisienne est entrée dans
l'année la nuque basse c'estàdire
qu'elle a réadopté le catogan cette
coiffure ravissante qui fut une part du
style 18e mais bien sûr un catogan
rageuni renouvelé ainsi le catogan de
Jacques de
[Musique]
S et celui d'Antoine Salvador d'une
audacieuse
[Musique]
fantaisie celui de Pierre Charby
classique dans sa jeunesse
[Musique]
d'expression et enfin celui si pur et si
Seillant sans nœud ni cocarde de Jacques
[Musique]
Dutour le joli retour du
catogan
le calendrier des postes que selon une
tradition toujours cherment appréciée
les préposés d'aujourd'hui dans leur
costume modèle 63 sont venus offrir pour
la nouvelle année à maintenant 110 ans
depuis 1854 date de sa naissance il
semble avoir mis un point d'honneur à se
faire dans un style changeant mais
toujours très particulier le reflet
disons de l'histoire de la famille
impériale à nos jours en passant par la
guerre de 70 pendant et après il a
imposé dans chaque FAM sa vision
sommaire des événements et de la vie
[Musique]
quotidienne avec les tram à chevaux des
Champs-Élysées et le lac hiilque du bois
de Boulogne c'est la vie sans souci de
la fin du siècle dernier le temps des
rendez-vous à la cascade de beaux
messieurs moustachux à cheval et de
jolie femmes en calèche c'est aussi le
temps béni des casinos et des
rassemblements fiévreux autour du tapis
[Musique]
vert 1900 on vient voir et complimenter
l'armée
française voici le temps des Vals et des
volants le temps des bains de mer à la
mode les mécaniques commencent à
impressionner sérieusement les jolies
promneuses la petite reine conquier le
beau sexe et lui apporte des sensations
nouvelles et puis c'est
1914 la jumelle rivé sur la
lefenseur de la patrie F allure comme
les compages cyclistes du début de la
guerre jusquà l'apparition du bleu
horizon qui créera la silhouette du
Poilu Eton attendra 4
ans 1925 c'est l'image de la femme au
volin et de la garçon le temps d'un
Charleston en attendant d'arriver à
l'autre guerre celle à qui ses engins
don une allure d'apocalypse
croiton C aussi dont l'exode est resté
dans les mémoires
et puis viendront les calendriers de la
[Musique]
Libération aujourd'hui le calendrier qui
tire à 15 millions d'exemplaires semble
faire quelques concession au style
américain à faire d'époque depuis 110
ans il fait ce qu'il peut pour suivre
son temps ce brave
calendrier
bien qu'il n'y ait pas de neige cette
année dans les Alpes les skilleuses
Françaises sont déjà prêtes pour les
Jeux Olympiques d'insbrook au Salom
spécial de grindelald malgré
l'Autrichienne trader malgré
l'américaine Jean sbert Mariel guachel
l'enfant sage du ski féminin français a
remporté une nouvelle victoire au cours
de cette épreuve Mariel guachel a joué
des héroïnes il lui a fallu subir un
véritable chemin de
croix après avoir heurté un piquet avec
une joue au cours de la première manche
la petite championne a dû ensuite éviter
un officiel qui malencontreusement était
tombé sur la piste miracle elle a quand
même gagné comme elle gagnera peut-être
les Jeux
[Musique]
Olympiques au cour du lobound à vengen
l'utrichien en Zimmerman et l'allemand
lutwiich lightner se sont partagés les
lauriers la victoire de lightner que
l'on voit ici dans le Salom spécial est
tiré par les cheveux aussi bien son
sourire après l'arrivée est un peu
crispé parce qu'il doit sa victoire à la
disqualification douteuse disons-le du
français Guy perya les juges ont dit
perya a manqué une porte ont-ils raison
regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien il semble si l'on en juge par ce
document que Guy perya n'est pas avalé
la porte apparemment il est bel et bien
passé entre les deux piquets quoi qu'il
en soit déclassé ou non après cette
course perilla est l'un des favoris
numéro 1 du slalom spécial des Jeux
Olympiques et c'est sans loute pour cela
qu'il est sans rancune contre son
vainqueur inattendu ludwi schleitner
quiil a quand même
félicité aux î hawï c'est le printemps
toute l'année la plage de mahaka c'est
une espèce de paradis terrestre un
paradis pour touristes riches en dollars
mais les rois de maahaka ce ne sont pas
les milliardaires ce sont les champions
du
surfing rien n'empêche d'être
milliardaire pour pratiquer le surfing
mais la qualité majeure pour un champion
de cette spécialité c'est surtout
l'audace et la souplesse et ce n'est pas
toujours suffisant pour pour éviter les
v
forces qu qu'il en soit faire du surfing
en plein hiver comme ces hawïiens c'est
un luxe qui fait rêver tout le monde et
bien regardons et
rêvons
et vive le surfing ça c'est du
sport au Havre le pack beaufance est
entré en cale sèche pour subir une
petite opération qui doit en faire le
plus stable des transatlantiques à la
place des deux hélices latérales à 4
pales il sera doté de deux nouvelles
hélices à 5 pales énorme fleurs d'acier
de 27 tonnes
[Musique]
chacune
désormais le navire aura ses quatre
hélices identiques ce qui lui conférera
une plus grande
[Musique]
souplesse sans doute les promeneurs des
jardins des Tuileries n'ont-ils jamais
prêté qu'une attention légère au statu
qui bordent les allées personne ne
regrettera qu'on leur substitue des
sculptures de
[Musique]
Maillol pour avoir une première idée de
ce qu'apportera cette substitution les
maquettes de 16 des plus belles œuvres
du grand arti disparus ont été disposés
dans les jardins demain les originaux
prendront leur place et selon le vœu de
Monsieur André mer les Tuileries
deviendront le premier musée de
sculpture en plein
[Applaudissements]
air les trois nyfes au détour d'une
pelouse n'est-ce pas un beau cadeau fait
à
Paris c'est ce même Paris qui vient
d'être le théâtre d'un drame aussi
incompréhensible
qu'inexcusable boulevard Le Fèvre la
carcasse de fer et de béton d'un
immeuble de 12 étages en construction
s'est effondré sans raison apparente
ensevelissant les ouvriers qui y
travaillaient jour et nuit les équipes
de secours se sont succédé on a
jusqu'ici retrouvé 23 cadavres on compte
également 17 blessés graves et quelques
blessés légers aucun espoir ne subsiste
de découvrir d'autres survivants il faut
que toute la lumière soit faite sur les
causes de cette catastrophe et que s les
besoins justice soit fait
[Musique]
une crise extrêmement grave oppose
l'état de Panama aux États-Unis gardien
et locataire de la zone du canal des
deux océans il a suffit d'un incident
pour mettre le feu aux poudre et faire
éclater la tension latente entretenue
par le désir panaméen de voir Modifier
le traité de 1903 qui fait du canal un
monopole américain la population s'est
soudain révoltée contre les détails
irritants d'une occupation consacré sans
doute par des traités mais qui tient mal
compte des intérêts
panaméens des manifestations se sont
déroulées en divers points de la zone du
canal des CS ont été échangés et le sang
a
coulé une trentaine de morts du côté
panaméen quatre du côté américain ont
rendu la crise
[Musique]
inéluctable
et les obsè des victimes ont marqué la
profondeur du drame l'unanimité du
peuple a approuvé la rupture des
relations diplomatiques avec les
États-Unis et le problème est d'autant
moins facile à résoudre que l'approche
des élections dans les deux pays ne peut
que durcir les
[Musique]
position c'est de façon tout à fait
impontu que le leader cubain FID Castro
a rendu à monsieurchov une nouvelle
visite à Moscou
en dépit des communiqués qui semble
indiquer que ce voyage est motivé par
des raisons de repos et de loisirs on
est facilement amené à penser que la
visite de Castro pourrait être liée à la
crise de Panama dans laquelle les
États-Unis ont déjà dénoncé les
influences
castriste une révolution vient de
bouleverser le tout jeune État de
Zanzibar qui n'accéda à l'indépendance
que le 10 décembre dernier un
ex-policier originaire du Kenya John
Okello a renversé le gouvernement s'est
proclamé maréchal et a pris le pouvoir
au nom de l'opposition africaine le
sultan ayant réussi à fuir les quelques
50000 Arabes qui tenaient les leviers de
commande tant politique qu'économique et
les 20000 Indiens qui formaient la
fraction commerçante ont été les
victimes de l'opération on les a
rassemblé dans des camps mais on parle
aussi de plusieurs milliers de
morts le spectacle des hôpitaux de
fortune ou les services de santé sont
restés sur place malgré l'évacuation des
Anglais démontrent le caractère sanglant
de cette révolution c'est ainsi que
l'île de la girofle est devenu la
république populaire de
zanziba
auoker le siège de la Ligue arabe a
servi de cadre à ce que l'on a appelé la
conférence au sommet du monde arabe sur
l'invitation du président Gamal Abdel
Nasser le roi husseain de Jordanie le
président Ben Bella le président
bourgiba le roi Hassan 2 du Maroc et les
chefs d'État ou les représentants des h
autres pays arabes se sont réunis pour
étudier en commun le moyen de s'opposer
au captage des EAU du Jourdain par
[Musique]
Israël la France et le Canada vont
organiser des consultations politiques
régulières ainsi en ont décidé le
général de Gaulle et le Premier ministre
canadien monsieur Lester Pearson venu
lui rendre une visite officielle une
soirée de gala à l'Élysée a marqué CE
voyage dont l'importance tant à l'égard
des relations franco-américaines que de
l'avenir de la communauté Atlantique ne
peut être
discuté il se peut d'ailleurs que de son
côté le général de Gaulle se rende
bientôt au
[Musique]
Canada de jeunes Français vont coopérer
à la promotion des populations
africaines monsieur Triboulet ministre
délégué chargé de la Coopération a
présenté au Premier ministre monsieur
George Pompidou le premier groupe des
volontaires du progrès 13 jeunes gens
qui ont décidé de mettre durant 2 ans
leurs compétences professionnelles au
service de la modernisation rurale d'une
nation d'Afrique
[Musique]
francophone rappelez que la colonne
vertébrale est l'axe de soutien
essentiel du corps est bien sûr un lieu
commun mais sans doute n'y pense-on
jamais assez pendant toute la vie en
effet la colonne vertébrale est mise à
Rud d'épreuve les gestes les plus
simples et les plus quotidiens la
malmène et requère d'elle des qualités
de solidité de résistance et de
souplesse assez évidentes pour qu'on la
prépare de bonheur aux nécessités de
notre vie
turbulante on ne surveille jamais trop
les mauvaises tenues des écoliers au
travail parfois dû à un éclairage
malorienté
ou ces attitudes si souvent observé de
ces enfants assis sur le bout de leur ch
et qui prennent avant l'âge un air
voûté que dire de ces cartables
surchargés à plaisir qui deviennent à la
longue des causes de déviation alors
qu'il suffit d'équiper les enfants de
cartable à bretelle ou de les obliger à
réduire le contenu au strict
minimum plutôt que de risquer d'en
arriver à de véritables déformations qui
une fois acquise demande un traitement
très long et très pénible il importe de
prévenir le mal à sa source une
musculature trop faible prédispose
l'enfant pendant toute sa croissance à
des
deevenir des déformations des exerci
correctifs appropriés sont alors
nécessaires pour aider à combattre les
mauvaises
attitudes dans ce domaine la natation
dirigée possède le maximum de valeur
thérapeutique dans la mesure où ére la
colonne vertébrale et renforce la sangle
musculaire qui tient l'édifice du Tron
la vie d'adulte réclame une constitution
sol il suffit en définitif de bien
petite servitude et d'un peu de
persévérance pour y préparer les
enfants
à Grenoble les Allemands de l'Ouest
Mar qui sont depuis de nombreuses années
déjà les enfants chér de la gloire ont
en sans difficulté le titre de champion
d'Europe de le spécialité Ils sont
inimitabl aucun couple de patineur
nteint une telle
perfection mais car il y a Mar et sont
au bord du divorce en tout bien honneur
puisquils ne sont pas mariés on leur
offre 50 millions par an pour passer
professionnel an a dit oui mais Marik a
dit non elle préfère le mariage à
l'argent résultat leur association va
bientôt prendre
fin Alain calma lui aussi au fait de la
gloire va décevoir tous ses admirateurs
dans un an on ne le reverra plus sur une
patinoire il a l'intention en effet de
troquer ses patins à glace contre la
blouse blanche du médecin alors
regardons-le et admirons pour l'une des
dernières fois l'un des plus grands de
tous les
[Musique]
temps et avant sa retraite Alain calma
pourrait bien ajouter à son titre de
champion d'Europe la médaille d'or des
Jeux
Olympiques
Paris qui comme on s aime à être étonné
va faire la connaissance d'inquiétant
coléoptère ce sont les dernières
créations d'un jeune peintre célèbre
passé à la sculpture Bernard Buffet car
c'est de lui qu'il s'agit est venu avec
sa femme Annabelle installer son Muséum
autrement dit sa collection d'insectes
de 2 m de haut fruit de 8 mois de
travail et résultat d'une vieille
passion l'histoire
naturelle l'occasion ne manquera pas de
rêver devant ces créatures faites de fil
de fer de câble électrique de plâtre de
TR métallique et de bande velp mais dont
la moindre vaut ses 6 millions de francs
ancien bien
[Musique]
entendu à 74 ans la Tour Effel peut
aujourd'hui espérer être classé monument
historique en même temps du reste qu'une
devanture du boulevard de la Madeleine à
et l'El particulier du verer Ren
[Musique]
l le principe en a été admis par la
commission supérieure des monuments
historiques soucieuse de nous conserver
intact des monuments de notre époque non
sans éclectisme puisquavec la synagogue
de la rue pavé un garage de la rue de
Pontieux serait également élevé à la
dignité de Monument Historique un garage
voilà bien un de ces monuments de notre
temps celui-là est en l'œuvre des frères
p
mais ne devrait-on pas faire un pas de
plus et penser aussi à sauver un des
derniers becs de
gaz ne devrait-on pas aussi classer un
de ces bistr à grille qui finiront par
disparaître si l'on a fait un sort au
moulin de la galette qui vit passer tant
de meunier et tant de Mimi Pinon ne
devrait-on pas en faire un à cette
édicule de Saint-Germain des PR qui fut
si intimement mêlé à la vie littéraire
d'après-gerre et faute d'avoir été
classé que deviendra cet éternel sauvé
des
EAU même dans les grands magasin
l'arrivée à Paris du groupe des Beatles
a déclenché un rush on sait qu'en dehors
de leur style vocal les Beatles ont mis
l'accent aussi sur l'originalité de leur
coiffure et la perruque Beatles fait en
ce moment les beaux jours d'une foule de
copains qui ont de l'enthousiasme à
revendre celle-là c'est du vrai
[Musique]
il paraît qu'une telle perruque va à
tout le monde il ne faut pas croire
toute fois qu'elle donne de la voix
dispense du talent et assure la
célébrité pas mal d'entre nous passerai
même ainsi coiffé pour de dou mais on
leur promet en tout cas un succès
ébourffant
[Musique]
dans la nuit des temps et dans la nuit
tout court des noms scintilles qui
évoquent des silhouettes ou des visages
mais Max Linder AE seulement le nom d'un
cinéma on le retrouve aujourd'hui après
un oubli de 40 ans grâce à l'amour de sa
fille ma de Linder de nouvelles foules
viennent remplacer les foules d'avant
l'autre guerre pour voir ce personnage
qui fut aux origine du cinéma le premier
grand comique et la première grande
vedette le cinéma avait 10 ans lorsqu'il
débuta mais rapidement son image emplit
les salles et couvrit les murs de Paris
c'eston qu'il fut à son époque la
première vedette internationale c'eston
qu'il fut de 1905 à 1925 l'auteur et
l'acteur de plus de 600 films et qu'il
toucha des cachets supérieurs à ceux de
l tayor et conquit un public plus grand
que celui de Brigitte bardau que
reste-t-il de cette vie fulgurante sa
villa de la vararen toujours debout mais
tombé au rang de Château de Belle au
bois
Dormand
les vieux studios de Vincen qui furent
le départ de gigantesques installations
de Hollywood l'hôtel où il se suicida un
jour de 1925 on l'a oublié pendant 40
ans pourtant quelle place fut la sienne
écoutons marcelch si je devais écrire
pour un dictionnaire académique une
définition de Max Linder je dirais
célèbre comique français qui par ses
inventions ses trouvailles ses gag son G
a été non seulement le précurseur mais
l'inventeur du comicque américain il
laissait un disciple génial char Chaplin
qui a dit sans Max Linder je n'aurais
jamais fait de cinéma je salue en lui
mon professeur et mon maître et il faut
rendre grâce à ma Linder la fille du
grand disparu qui après des années de
recherch et de patience a su nous
réapprendre le nom de ce père qu'elle
n'a pas connu et dont le visage nous
redevient vivant comme celui d'un ami
retrouvé vous allez voir le 7e épisode
de soyez ma femme vous n'avez pas oublié
que Max est fiancé avec la ravissante
esméraldine il se rend chez un très
grand couturier pour lui offrir la robe
de ses rêves mais comme toujours de
nombreuses Aventur
[Musique]
l'attend
le Grand Prix d'Amérique a fait vivre la
France entière dans la fièvre durant les
quelques minutes de la course 5 milliard
de Paris il est vrai justifia cette
effervescence dans les tribunes et sur
la plous de V 45000 spectateurs
vociférant le gagnant ce ne sera pas
celui-là Patara le numéro 14 va être
victime d'un drame ce trotteur
magnifique va disparaître juste avant la
dernière ligne droite le SU heurtera un
piquet de la corde et si Monard le
driver sera prjeté au sol
bien malin celui qui avait pensé au
vainqueur vous le voyez qui déboule en
tête c'est le 13 le cheval
italoaméricain Nike Hanover il apporte
une fortune sous ses sabots à ceux qui
ont le FL de lui faire
confiance 13 9 12 un tic que les
gagnants ne sont pas prêts
[Musique]
d'oublier cette jeune femme de 32 ans
vaaire seule àord d'un av de 180 chevaux
la ligne héroïque de jeanmerm parti dis
soir en 40 he de vol elle veut atteindre
rio janeiro deux femmes seulement avant
elle ont réalisé cet exploit la
Néerlandaise John bon en 1931 et maris
Bastier en 1935 depuis ni homme ni femme
personne n'a renouvelé cette
performance voici son plan de vol en
tout 10000 km dont plus de 3000 km
auessus de l'Atlantique même à l'époque
des cosmonautes c'est encore un
expo c'est au Canada que se déroule
cette scène mais n'allz surtout pas
croire que les Canadiens ont la
bougeotte et qu'ils déplacent comme cela
leur petit chalet par goût des voyages
pas du tout c'est pour aller à la pêche
que les habitants du village canadien
français de Saint-Anne de la Pérade
effectuent ce déménagement ils aiment la
pêche mais la pêche dans le confort
alors comme les poissons ne viennent pas
tout seul chez eux dans leur appartement
pour mordre à l'hameçon Cassel tienne
petit poisson c'est la maison qui va
jusqu'à vous et qui s'installe sur le
lac
gelé
et voilà le tour est joué on peut comme
cela pêcher du poisson frais tout en
fumant sa pipe au coin du feu ou en
continuant de vivre comme chez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
soi